From kindergarten to college, most students and teachers focus on mastering content, reading, writing, math, science, and history. But along the way, very few students are taught a crucial skill set. What exactly is the best way to learn? Decades of research in psychology have found that some study techniques are far more effective than others, but the most effective teaching and learning methods are not always the most popular ones. So students end up wasting time and effort using study strategies that don't help them acquire new knowledge and get frustrated in the process. Which study techniques do work and which ones don't?
从幼儿园到大学，大多数学生和老师都专注于掌握内容，包括阅读、语文、数学、科学和历史。但在此过程中，很少有学生被教导一套至关重要的技能。到底什么才是最好的学习方法？心理学数十年的研究发现，某些学习方法的效率远高于其他方法，但最高效的教与学方法往往并不是最受欢迎的方法。因此，学生最终浪费了时间和精力去使用那些无法帮助他们获取新知识的学习策略，并在这一过程中感到沮丧。哪些学习方法管用，哪些不管用？
Is it useful to take copious notes, to read every section of a textbook multiple times, to highlight key points on a page? What about cramming? Can students cram their way to an A? And do the same study strategies work for everyone? Or are there techniques that work well for some people and not for others? What about those of us who are no longer in school? Can the same learning skills help lifelong learners master knitting or learn to retile their bathroom or acquire some other new knowledge or skill? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills.
做大量的笔记、多次阅读教科书的每一节、用荧光笔标记页面上的重点，这些有用吗？临时抱佛脚呢？学生能通过突击复习拿A吗？同样的学习策略对每个人都管用吗？还是说某些方法对一部分人管用，对其他人不管用？那些已经不在学校的人呢？同样的学习技能能否帮助终身学习者掌握编织、学会重新铺设浴室瓷砖或掌握其他新知识或技能？欢迎收听“心理学热话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。
We have two guests today. They're the co-authors of a new book from APA called Study Like a Champ, the Psychologist, the Psychology-based Guide to Grade A Study Habits, which will be published in January. First is Dr. Regan Gurung, a professor and director of the General Psychology Program at Oregon State University. He studies social and health psychology as well as the psychology of teaching and learning. He's the founding editor of APA's journal Scholarship of Teaching and Learning in Psychology and is a past president of the Society for Teaching of Psychology, APA's Division 2. Before moving to Oregon in 2019, he's
今天我们请来了两位嘉宾。他们是APA将于1月出版的新书《像冠军一样学习：基于心理学的优等生学习习惯指南》（Study Like a Champ: The Psychology-Based Guide to Grade A Study Habits）的合著者。首先是雷根·古龙（Regan Gurung）博士，他是俄勒冈州立大学普通心理学项目的教授兼主任。他研究社会与健康心理学以及教与学的心理学。他是APA期刊《心理学教与学学术》（Scholarship of Teaching and Learning in Psychology）的创刊主编，曾任APA第二分部“心理学教学协会”（Society for Teaching of Psychology）的主席。在2019年搬到俄勒冈州之前，他曾
taught at the University of Wisconsin Green Bay for 20 years. Next is Dr. John Dunlowski, a professor of psychology and director of the Science of Learning and Education Center at Kent State University. Dr. Dunlowski's research focuses on discovering the techniques that students can use to improve their learning and achievement. He is author of more than 150 peer-reviewed journal articles and has written or edited eight books, including the most recent one from APA. Thank you both for joining me today. It's our pleasure to be here. Absolutely. Let's start with the big picture. Why is it important to teach students how to learn rather than just teaching them content? How much difference does it make in terms of what they can achieve? That's a great place to start, Kim, because when we think about
在威斯康星大学绿湾分校任教20年。另一位是约翰·敦洛斯基（John Dunlosky）博士，他是肯特州立大学的心理学教授兼学习与教育科学中心主任。敦洛斯基博士的研究重点是发现学生可以用来提高学习和成绩的技术。他是150多篇同行评审期刊文章的作者，并撰写或编辑了八本书，其中包括最近由APA出版的那一本。非常感谢二位今天能抽空参加节目。这是我们的荣幸。当然。让我们从宏观层面开始。为什么教学生如何学习比单纯教他们内容更重要？这在他们所能取得的成就方面能带来多大差异？这是一个很好的切入点，金，因为当我们思考
teaching and learning and college, so often we focus on content and content delivery. And when I say we both, I think, parents, teachers, students, faculty, but the reality is, to really get that content in and hang on to it for the long term, true learning, you've got to take a look at skills. You've got to take a look at techniques. And this is where the plot thickens because not every class is the same. Not every discipline is the same. And so the more you learn those basic skills,
大学里的教与学时，我们经常把重点放在内容和内容的传授上。当我用“我们”时，我认为包括父母、老师、学生和教职员工，但现实是，要想真正吸收这些内容并在长期内牢记它们——也就是真正的学习——你必须关注技能。你必须关注方法。这就是问题变得复杂的地方，因为并非每一堂课都一样。并非每一个学科都一样。因此，你学到的基本技能越多，
the more you learn a wide array of skills and different tools, you can then use the best one for the, for the, best class to get the most long-term learning. So really our thought was, yes, content is important, but without the right skills to get that content in, you're not going to remember it for a very long time. And that truly was that inspiration for the two of us going. You know, we do all this research on learning. There's all this research about in the lab. But one of the reasons I loved working with John on this is both of us not only do basic research in labs, but we all also work in the classroom. And over the far too many years that we want to admit to, years of
你学到的广泛技能和不同工具越多，你就能为最好的课程选择最合适的方法，从而获得最多的长远学习成果。所以我们的真实想法是，是的，内容很重要，但如果没有吸收这些内容的正确技能，你是记不住很长时间的。这确实是我们两人开始做这件事的灵感来源。你知道，我们对学习进行了所有这些研究。实验室里有各种各样的研究。但我喜欢和约翰合作的原因之一是，我们俩不仅在实验室里做基础研究，我们还在教室里工作。在我们愿意承认的漫长教学岁月中，
teaching, we've worked with just so many students and seen the problems that students have in the trenches, as it were. And that's what this endeavor is all about. We've seen what happens in the classroom. We've seen where learning fails. And let's put together those things that can really arm students to tackle whichever class they're in. And as you nicely alluded to in the intro, not just in the classroom, anytime anybody wants to learn something, there are skills in here that can help you do it better. Dr. Dunlowski, let me ask you this. There are a lot of misconceptions and myths about learning and how to study.
我们与如此多的学生合作过，看到了学生在实际教学一线（可以说是壕沟里）遇到的问题。这就是这项努力的全部意义所在。我们看到了课堂上发生的事情。我们看到了学习在哪些地方失败了。让我们把那些真正能武装学生应对任何课程的东西整合起来。正如你在引言中巧妙暗示的那样，不仅在课堂上，只要任何人想学东西，这里都有能帮你做得更好的技能。敦洛斯基博士，我想问您这个问题：关于学习和如何学习，有很多误解和迷思。
What are some of the big ones and what are the strategies that students are using that really aren't working very well for them? I think one of the biggest myths, and I really love this question, because I think we all hold some of these myths in different context, is that. that if learning is difficult, then it must be bad. It's taking you in the wrong direction. And it just turns out that many techniques that one uses to learn effectively are going to actually produce difficulties or struggles in your learning. So to think that, well, if I'm really struggling at something, I must not be going about it the right way is kind of a myth because
其中最大的迷思有哪些？学生们正在使用哪些其实对他们没有太大帮助的策略？我认为最大的迷思之一——我真的很喜欢这个问题，因为我认为我们在不同的语境中都多多少少抱有一些这样的迷思——那就是，如果学习很困难，那它一定是不好的。它把你带往了错误的方向。但事实证明，为了有效学习而使用的许多技术实际上会在你的学习中产生困难或挣扎。因此，认为“如果我在某事上真的很挣扎，我一定是用错了方法”，这其实是一个迷思，因为
often if you're not struggling, you probably aren't making progress to your learning goal. It turns out that learning is just difficult. So to think that the only way it should happen is under easy context, and if it's difficult, I must not be good at this content. It's a really horrible myth, and I think it holds students back. It's very relevant to your first question when we see the student who's frustrated because they're struggling at a particular course. It's not because they don't have the ability to learn that content well and to perform well.
通常情况下，如果你没有感到挣扎，你可能就没有朝着学习目标取得进展。事实证明，学习本身就是困难的。因此，认为学习只应在轻松的环境下发生，如果很难，我一定不擅长这些内容，这是一个非常糟糕的迷思，我认为它阻碍了学生的发展。这与你的第一个问题非常相关，当我们看到学生因为在一门特定课程中苦苦挣扎而感到沮丧时。这并不是因为他们没有能力学好这些内容并取得优异成绩。
They're just not approaching it with the best strategies. Unfortunately, the misconceptions also work in the other direction that some of the strategies that students use a lot that are easy to use actually lead to good learning, such as just rereading your textbook and so forth. It gives you the sense of familiarity, so you feel good about it, hey, I know what this is all about, but it turns out that something that's like reading or rereading, which is a bit more passive, it doesn't lead to those gains and performance that you might expect. It may make you feel good because, hey, this is familiar, it's easy to do.
他们只是没有用最好的策略去接近它。不幸的是，误解也会朝另一个方向起作用，即学生经常使用的一些易于使用的策略实际上会导致良好的学习，比如只去重读教科书等等。这会给你一种熟悉感，让你感觉很好，“嘿，我知道这是怎么回事了”，但事实证明，像阅读或重读这种比较被动的事情，并不会带来你所期望的性能提升。它可能会让你感觉良好，因为，“嘿，这很熟悉，做起来很容易”。
But sometimes the pathway to success, there's going to be some struggles in there. And you should expect them and embrace them. So what are some of the techniques that do work? What does the research say about the best way to learn something new and make it stick? Well, the good news is that there are a lot of strategies that are relatively effective. And what Regan and I try to do was really pare down the field to just those most effective. strategies that are cost-free, any student can use these, right? They're inexpensive, but also are going to have a relatively broad, general impact on learning. And many of these
但有时通往成功的道路上会有一些挣扎。你应该预料到它们并拥抱它们。那么，哪些技术是真正管用的？研究对于学习新知识并使其牢记的最佳方法是怎么说的？好消息是，有很多策略是相对有效的。雷根和我试图做的是将这些领域缩小到最有效的那些——无需成本的策略，任何学生都可以使用，对吧？它们既便宜，又对学习产生相对广泛的普遍影响。其中许多
strategies improve students learning in two ways. They have a direct effect. So if you use them, it's going to boost your learning and maintenance and understanding of that content. The second is an indirect effect where if you use these strategies, and this is where the struggling comes in, It's going to allow you to detect when you don't understand something, which can be extremely frustrating. However, I'm saying that's an indirect effect of these strategies is because students should want to know what they're struggling with so that they can readjust, get help with some of their friends from instructors and so forth, so it's kind of to meet those learning struggles.
策略以两种方式改善学生的学习。它们有直接效果。因此，如果你使用它们，它将促进你对该内容的学习、保持和理解。其次是间接效果，如果你使用这些策略——这就是挣扎发挥作用的地方——它将使你能够检测到你什么时候不理解某些东西，这可能会极其令人沮丧。然而，我说这是这些策略的间接效果，是因为学生应该想要知道他们在哪里挣扎，以便他们可以重新调整、从朋友和导师那里获得帮助等等，所以这是一种迎战这些学习困难的方式。
My favorite technique, actually, is one of the easiest to use, and it's simply testing yourself or taking practice exams or practice retrieval. And the idea here is that when you try to practice retrieving something from memory, not simply just reading that content again, you get the both direct and indirect effect. If you can retrieve content accurately from memory, it turns out you get this wonderful boost in your long-term retention of that content. However, if you can't retrieve it yet or you struggle retrieving it, it's a really good signal that you need to do more to learn that content. So here's a strategy that produces these inherent struggles that might be frustrating, but those frustrations then can learn subsequent
我最喜欢的技术实际上是最容易使用的技术之一，它就是自我测试、参加模拟考试或练习提取。这里的想法是，当你尝试练习从记忆中提取某样东西，而不仅仅是再次阅读该内容时，你会同时获得直接和间接效果。如果你能准确地从记忆中提取内容，事实证明，你对该内容的长期保留会得到极大的提升。然而，如果你还不能提取它或者提取时很挣扎，这是一个很好的信号，表明你需要做更多的事情来学习该内容。所以，这里有一个策略，它会产生这些可能令人沮丧的固有困难，但这些挫折随后可以转化为成功，因为学生学会了锁定他们挣扎的地方，从而弥合这些困难。所以这是我们在书中讨论的众多策略之一。古龙博士，还有什么你想提出来的吗？
successes as students learn to hone in on what they're struggling with so they can bridge those difficulties. So that's one of many strategies that we discuss in the book. Dr. Goring, any others that you want to put out there? Yeah, you know, I'm glad John jumped in on that one because I was thinking, wow, there are so many we want to talk about. There is another strategy, but I'm going to tease you and not even go to that strategy and say even before we think about strategies, we've actually got to prepare for how we are going to learn.
是的，你知道，我很高兴约翰插话讲了这一点，因为我当时在想，哇，有太多我们想谈论的内容了。还有另一个策略，但我打算卖个关子，甚至不谈那个策略，而是说，在我们考虑策略之前，我们实际上必须为我们将如何学习做好准备。
And I think something that we spend a lot of time on right up front, you know, we start with some myths. But really, the place we start is planning because a large part of learning. And, I mean, you know, whether it's life, general or college where the average student is taking five classes, you know, that's a lot, that's a lot of content. That's a lot to learn. That's why one of the first things we say is you've got to make sure you have a good plan down, you know, work out a good way to schedule when you're going to study, when you're going to learn. So even before we get to repeat, you know,
我认为我们在最开始花了很多时间的事情，你知道，我们从一些迷思开始。但实际上，我们开始的地方是规划，因为学习很大程度上……我的意思是，你知道，无论是生活一般情况还是大学，平均一个学生要修五门课，你知道，这很多，内容非常多。要学的东西太多了。这就是为什么我们首先要说的是，你必须确保制定一个好的计划，你知道，制定一个好的时间表，安排你什么时候学习，什么时候学习。所以，在我们甚至谈到重复之前，你知道，
retrieval practice or testing yourself, make sure you have a good plan for when you're going to study. When are you going to study what? If you've got five classes, when in the week you study becomes really important. So I think planning is a very, very big part of learning that somehow falls off the radar when we think about strategy. So I want to make sure that it's up front and good. Planning is really important. Right next to planning, and even before we get to retrieval practice, I want to pick up something that on something that you said in your intro, which was the copious notes, right? right there is when John and I look out at our classrooms, we shed this very early in the writing
检索练习或自我测试，确保你有一个关于什么时候学习的好计划。你什么时候学什么？如果你有五门课，你在星期的什么时候学习变得非常重要。所以我认为规划是学习中非常非常大的一部分，而我们在考虑策略时，不知为何忽视了它。所以我想确保它被放在前面并且做好。规划真的很重要。紧挨着规划，甚至在我们进入检索练习之前，我想接着你刚才在引言中说的一点，那就是大量的笔记，对吧？就在这里，当约翰和我审视我们的教室时，我们在写作的早期阶段就抛开了这一点。
process. Something we noticed is that students aren't taking notes as much. And boy, whether it's you listening to a master class on cooking or, you know, taking an online class or sitting in one of our classes, note taking is one of those hidden gems where note taking, is a strategy in itself. And I think we have to realize that the process of taking notes actually helps us organize out the material and is a tool in itself that is vastly underutilized. So my first book, you know, I said we've got a plan,
我们注意到的一件事是，学生做笔记越来越少了。天哪，无论你是听一堂烹饪大师课，还是上在线课程，或者坐在我们的课堂里，记笔记都是那些隐藏的瑰宝之一，记笔记本身就是一种策略。我认为我们必须认识到记笔记的过程实际上有助于我们整理材料，并且它本身就是一个被严重低估的工具。所以我的第一本书，你知道，我说过我们必须有计划，
we've got to make sure we take good notes, and then I'm going to hand the pass over to John to go for the next big one, which is spacing. spacing out your studying. Job, there's the pass. Yeah, it turns out that spacing your practice is very important strategy to use. And note, this is actually important misconception about spacing that many students hold, many instructors hold, is that spacing merely means that I'm going to study for a course
我们必须确保做好笔记，然后我要把接力棒交个约翰，讲下一个重要的事情，那就是间隔。间隔你的学习。约翰，接力棒交给你了。是的，事实证明，间隔练习是非常重要的策略。请注意，关于间隔，其实有一个非常重要的误解，许多学生和许多导师都持有这种误解，即间隔仅仅意味着我将为一门课程学习
on more than one occasion. That's a very good thing to do. It means you're just not cramming, but spacing means studying the same concept. content in one or more sessions. So just not studying in one or more sessions. And note, once I say this, well, you have to study in one or more sessions. It kind of ties that bow with what Regan was saying about planning. In order to use some of these strategies with fidelity, students need to manage their time, that is, set up multiple, say, study sessions for each class prior to an exam to get ready for it. Because if you just wait to cram the night before, which I'm not suggesting students don't
不止一次。这是一件非常好的事情。这意味着你不仅仅是在突击复习，但间隔意味着在一次或多次会议中学习相同的概念内容。而不仅仅是在一次或多次会议中学习。请注意，一旦我这么说，好吧，你必须在一次或多次会议中学习。这就把雷根关于规划的说法完美地结合起来了。为了忠实地使用其中一些策略，学生需要管理他们的时间，也就是说，在考试前为每门课设立多个学习课程来做好准备。因为如果你只是等到前一天晚上突击复习——我不建议学生不这样做，也就是说，所有学生都会突击复习，只要你做得更多。
do, that is, all students cram, just as you do more than that. And you're going to have to plan and manage your time accordingly to take advantage of this really impactful strategy, which, by the way, students use in every other context they learn in, except for an educational context. It's a really effective strategy. We just forget about it when we start studying for our classes. So, when you talk about spacing, is there some ideal? I mean, how much do you space things out? And I think you've also found interleaving is effective as well. Maybe you can explain what that means.
你将不得不相应地规划和管理你的时间，以利用这个非常具有影响力的策略，顺便说一句，学生在他们学习的每个其他环境中都在使用这个策略，除了教育环境。这是一个非常有效的策略。当我们开始为课程学习时，我们只是忘记了它。所以，当你谈论间隔时，有什么理想的标准吗？我的意思是，你把事情间隔多久？我想你还发现交错练习也很有效。也许你可以解释一下这意味着什么。
First, there's no definitive answer to how much you should space your practice. In fact, how much is going to depend on in kind of technical terms, the forgetting rate for the particular content, because the idea is that you want to come back to that material right before you're going to forget it. And for different kinds of material, depending on your background, that interval might be different lengths. The good news is, I don't think we have to have a definitive answer for students. Because often how much you want to space your practice is defined by your syllabus. You'll have so many exams over this space of a semester, and you have, say, three or four weeks to study for each exam. So that's about how much time you have to prepare.
首先，对于你应该把练习间隔多久，并没有明确的答案。事实上，间隔多久取决于用专业术语来说就是特定内容的遗忘率，因为这里的想法是，你希望在你要忘记该材料之前重新接触它。对于不同种类的材料，根据你的背景，这个间隔可能是不同的长度。好消息是，我认为我们不必为学生提供一个明确的答案。因为你希望把练习间隔多久，通常是由你的教学大纲决定的。在一个学期的跨度内，你会有很多考试，比如每场考试你有三到四周的时间来复习。所以这差不多就是你准备的时间。
So typically I recommend if students can study twice a week for a particular class, well, the spacing will be two or three days to space that practice out, which is pretty good. I think if students would put on their schedules, I'm going to study for each class twice a week and come back to the same material on every one of those sessions, they'll see a really nice benefit to their performance because they're spacing their practice. Now, with respect to interleaving, that's kind of a complicated strategy, and it means that you're going to study different content intermixed. And specifically, it works well for content that you'd get confused about or that you would confuse with one another. So imagine studying for a math exam.
因此，通常我建议如果学生每周可以为特定课程学习两次，那么间隔练习的时间将是两到三天，这相当不错。我认为如果学生在日程表上写下：我将每周为每门课学习两次，并且在每一次学习中都回到相同的材料，他们会看到他们的表现有一个非常好的提升，因为他们在进行间隔练习。现在，关于交错练习，这是一种比较复杂的策略，这意味着你要把不同的内容混合在一起学习。具体来说，它非常适合那些你会感到困惑或者容易互相混淆的内容。想象一下准备数学考试。
And you know you're going to be tested on a variety of different math problems, say different calculus problems where you have to differentiate equations and so forth. One of the difficulties of doing that, and there are many of solving those kinds of problems, is just identifying exactly what kind of problem this is. Interleaving gives students the practice of comparing and contrasting different problems, so the first thing they need to do is to identify what kind of problem is this, and hence what solution should I have? Typically, however, most students and most textbooks are set up this way, so that you practice the same kind of problem in mass. So when you go to the next one, you know exactly what kind of problem it is, you're practicing
你知道你要接受各种不同数学微积分问题的测试，比如你必须对方程进行微分等等。这样做（解决这类问题）的困难之一，就是准确识别这究竟是什么类型的问题。交错练习给学生提供了比较和对比不同问题的练习，所以他们要做的第一件事就是识别这是什么类型的问题，从而决定我应该用什么解法？通常情况下，大多数学生和大多数教科书都是这样设置的，即你集中练习同一种类型的问题。所以当你去做下一个时，你确切地知道这是什么问题，你只是在练习我能否应用正确的解法。
just can I apply the right solution. So interleaving actually helps students to mix up different problems so they can get better at identifying what kind of problem is this and then how should I solve it. Quite frankly, one of the biggest benefits of interleaving is that it forces students to space practice because by the necessity, if you're interleaving different concepts and coming back to the old ones, you'll also have a lot of space practice in your interleaved practice. We talk a lot about the details about how to implement this in the book because they're a little bit more complicated than we can portray in the podcast. But all of these can be, again, easily used by students
因此，交错练习实际上帮助学生将不同的问题混合起来，这样他们就能更好地识别这是什么类型的问题，然后我该如何解决它。坦率地说，交错练习最大的好处之一是它迫使学生进行间隔练习，因为根据需要，如果你在交错不同的概念并回到旧概念，你在交错练习中也会有很多间隔练习。我们在书中详细讨论了如何实施这一点，因为它们比我们在播客中描述的要稍微复杂一些。但只要学生管理好时间并为每门课规划不同的学习环节，所有这些都可以再次被学生轻松使用。古龙博士，刚才你谈到了准备，谈到了学生为学习做准备有多重要。我想知道，周围环境重要吗？你在哪里学习？有些人喜欢背景音乐。这会让你的学习更有效还是更无效？这会因人而异吗？
as long as they manage their time and plan for different study episodes for each class. Dr. Gurring, you were talking a little while ago about preparing, how it's important for a student to prepare to study. And I'm wondering, does it matter your surroundings, where you study? And some people like to have music in the background. Is that something that makes your studying more or less effective? Does it vary from person to person? So, yeah, distractions are something pretty big to focus on. And when we think about distractions, you know, I wish it was only music.
所以，是的，分心是一个非常需要关注的大问题。当我们想到分心时，你知道，我希望这仅仅是音乐，但对于普通人来说，更不用说普通学生了，对普通人来说，周围总有一部手机，也许还有，你知道的，如果你是个老古董的话，有Instagram或Facebook，或者Twitter，或者现在的Mastodon。你知道，周围到处都是这些东西。但很多时候，人们认为，你知道，音乐是好的、舒缓的。关于音乐，特别有趣的是，我们需要记住的关键一点是，任何消耗心理能量的东西都在消耗他们原本用于专注的能量。这是一个非常基础的核心。如果我试图阅读某些东西，如果我周围有对话，如果周围有音乐，如果电视开着并且在播放流媒体，我大脑中原本用来关注我正在阅读的内容的那部分现在正在
but for the average person, let alone the average student, but the average person, there's a cell phone around, there maybe, you know, Instagram or Facebook, if you're an oldie, you know, or Twitter or maybe Mastodon now. You know, it's all these things all around. But very often people, I think, believe that, you know, music is good and soothing. And what's really interesting about, especially music, is that just the key thing for us to remember is just anything that's using mental energy is taking energy away from what they're focusing on. That's something really at the basic core. If I am trying to read something, if there's a conversation around me, if there's music around me, if the TV is on and something is streaming, a part of my brain that would be paying attention to what I'm reading is now. paying attention to some of those other facts. When you think about it from, especially when we think about it from a neuroscience perspective
关注其他一些事情。当你从神经科学的角度，特别是从认知神经科学的角度来思考这个问题时，一种思考方式是，要记住我们的工作记忆容量是有限的。它的容量有限，我们存储材料的持续时间也有限。所以我们的任务是将材料从工作记忆中取出并转移到长期记忆中。为了帮助我们的大脑将东西从工作记忆转移到长期记忆，我们能做的最好的事情之一就是注意并专注于我们正在阅读和做的事情。因为我们越关注它，我们就越能把事情更好地送入长期记忆。现在请注意，检索练习是另一种增强长期记忆中记忆的方法，这一切都是联系在一起的。
and a cognitive neuroscience perspective, one way to think about it is, to remember is our working memory has a limited capacity. It's got a limited capacity and it's got a limited duration where we can store material. So our task is to take material from working memory and get it into. to long-term memory. And one of the best things we can do to help our brains move things from working memory to long-term memory is to pay attention and focus on what we're reading and doing. Because the more we focus on it, the more, the better we can get things to long-term memory. Now, mind you, retriever practice is another one of those things that strengthens the memories in long-term
但追溯到你的问题，你学习的环境会产生巨大的差异。一个很好的底线是，如果你能减少干扰，你就能越专注于你所学的内同，你就越有可能关注它，你对它的加工就可能越深，这反过来又与长期记忆有关。让我们花一分钟时间来谈谈所谓的学习风格。APA去年发表了一项研究，对许多人（包括教育工作者）的一种信念提出了挑战，即学习风格是天生固定的，并且它们可以预测学业和职业成功。你们俩是否认为人们具有内在的学习风格（无论是听觉的、视觉的还是触觉的），并且有必要针对这些风格进行教学？
memory and this all ties together. But going all the way back to your question, the setting in which you study can make the world of a difference. And a nice bottom line is if you can cut down on distractions, the more you can focus on what you're studying, the more likely you are to pay attention to it, the deeper you are likely to process it, which in turn is related to longer term memory. Let's talk for a minute about something called learning styles. APA published a study last year, challenging the belief among many, including educators, that learning styles are set at birth and that they predict academic and career success. Do either of you believe that people have an inherent learning style, whether that's auditory, visual, or tactical, and that it's necessary
根据所有的证据，金，我的结论是：不，人们没有学习风格。他们确实有学习偏好，我对这些偏好表示验证和尊重。有些人喜欢视觉化地看东西。有些人喜欢听、感受或触摸它们。但这些偏好并不能转化为学习成果。一个简单的例子是，假设你是一个听觉学习者。而我在教你，我们回到微积分。我可以要么用语言向你描述方程，因为你是听觉型的，要么我可以通过在黑板上画出方程来向你展示。不需要太多的思考就能意识到，在那里对你最有效的技术，
to teach to those styles? Based on all the evidence, Kim, my conclusion is that, no, people do not have learning styles. They do have learning preferences and those I validate and respect. Some people like to see things visually. Some people like to hear them, feel them, touch them. But those preferences don't translate into learning outcomes. And one simple example would be is let's say you're a auditory learner. And I'm teaching you, we'll go back to calculus. And I can either describe the equations in words to you because you're auditory, or I can show you by drawing the equations up on the board. It doesn't take lots of thinking to realize that the most effective technique there for you,
无论你的偏好如何，都是把这个写在黑板上，因为要用口头把所有这些都解读清楚是非常困难的。事实证明，有些内容最好使用特定的模态来教授和学习，无论是视觉的、听觉的，还是多种模态。但认为教师可以通过弄清楚每个人有什么风格然后针对该风格进行教学来使学生受益，这不仅在课堂上很可能无法有效发生，而且确实不应该发生，因为它不会带来更好的学习成果。
regardless of your preference, is to write this on the board because it would be very difficult to decipher all of that verbally. It just turns out that some content is best taught and best learned using a particular modality, whether it's visual, auditory, maybe multiple modalities. But to think that instructor is going to benefit their students by figuring out what every style someone has and then teaching that style is not only something that's probably not going to happen in the classroom effectively, but really shouldn't happen because it's not going to lead to better gains in learning.
所以这是我自己的观点，但也许雷根对此有不同的看法。嗯，你知道，我实际上要补充这一点，并聚焦于教师部分，因为我认为这里非常重要的是，首先，积累的证据表明，学习风格更多属于迷思的水平。Pashler及其同事在2007年发表了一篇很棒的文章，我认为它基本上给“学习风格在课堂中很重要”这种观念钉上了最后一颗棺材钉。但我认为人们经常忽略的一点是——约翰也提到了这一点，但我真的很想强调这一点——教师将教学风格与学习风格相匹配并没有被发现是一种有效的方法。事实上，几年前我自己就做过一项研究，我们发表了一项研究，实际上是为了进行测试而修改了针对学习风格的教学风格。绝对没有任何效果。积累的证据甚至更进一步指出，你准备好了吗？
So that's my own perspective, but maybe Regan has got a different spin on all of this. Well, you know, I'm actually going to add to that and hone in on the instructor part because I think what's really important here is, first off, the accumulated evidence that suggests that learning styles are more the myth level. There was a great article that actually came out in 2007 by Pashler and colleagues that pretty much put the final nail, I think, in this notion that, you know, learning styles are important in the classroom. But I think what's often missed, and John alluded to this, but I really want to underscore it, is that the teacher matching a teaching style to a learning style has just not been found to be an effective way to go. And in fact, actually, I did a study on this myself where we, some years ago, where we published a study actually modifying a teaching style for a learning style, just to put it to the test. absolutely no effects whatsoever. And the accumulated evidence goes even further to say that, are you ready for it?
学生实际上受益于教师使用不同的风格。所以不仅仅是“请用我的风格教我”，而是“不，如果我的教师使用多种风格，我实际上会学得更好”。这一点非常重要，因为我知道约翰和我听过学生说：“哦，我不喜欢那门课。我是一个视觉学习者，但他们用了别的风格。我希望他们用我的风格。”在这里，数据表明，不，作为一名学生和学习者，教师使用不同的风格对你来说要好得多，远胜于我们实际去匹配风格。所以不要责怪老师。
Students actually benefit from instructors using different styles. So it's not just, please teach me in my style, it's no, I'm actually going to learn better if my instructor is using multiple styles. And this is so important because I know John and I have both heard students say, oh, I don't like that class. I'm such a visual learner, but they use some other style. I wish they used my style. Here, the data says, no, actually, using different styles as an instructor is way better for you as a student and a learner than if we actually try to match
不要责怪老师。数据表明，多种教学风格更好。这一点非常重要，因为，你知道，尽管数据在07年就出来了，但我看到最近的调查（特别是K-12教育）仍然存在这种学习风格的概念。你知道，那是老黄历了，早就过去了。让我们继续前进。让我们专注于真正有帮助的事情，比如，你知道，检索练习和间隔练习，这是我们的挑战，我们如何帮助我们的学生练习这些技能、这些将帮助他们学习的技术？这是一个更大的挑战。学习需要死记硬背的东西（比如拼写或乘法表）与学习需要对概念或想法有更深理解的东西之间有什么区别吗？你们谈论的技术能帮助这两种类型的学习吗？
styles. So don't blame the instructor. Don't blame the instructor. The data says multiple teaching styles are better. And this is so important because, you know, even though the data came out in 07, I've seen even recent surveys of particularly K through 12 instruction where this notion of learning styles still persist. You know, it's been there, done that a long time ago. Let's move on. Let's focus on things that actually help like, you know, retriever practice and spacing practice, that's our challenge, is how do we help our students practice these skills, these techniques that will help them learn? That's the bigger challenge. Is there a difference between learning something that requires memorization, say spelling or
我想答案是肯定的。许多一般性策略当然都是针对并被许多人认为能够促进内容的记忆和保留的。像检索练习这样的事情，你从记忆中提取某样东西，以后就能更好地记住它。然而，这里的想法是，很大一部分理解力被——我不想说被高估或过度吹捧，它非常重要——但我认为发生的情况是记忆被低估了。
the multiplication tables, and learning something that requires a deeper understanding of concepts or ideas? Can the techniques that you're talking about help with both of those types of learning? I would say the answer is yes. Many of the general strategies, certainly are set up and many believe promote memory and retention of the content. Something like retrieval practice, well, you retrieve something from memory and you remember it better later on. The idea here, though, is that much of comprehension is, I don't want to say overrated or overtouted, it's very important, but I think what happens is that memory is underrated.
例如，如果我不记得一个被理解的概念，我怎么能应用它呢？因此，这里的想法是，我们越多地使用这些记忆策略来学习需要理解的困难内容，当我们在随后需要使用它时，我们就会拥有越多的可用内容。那么我们描述的任何策略都是所有学习的灵丹妙药吗？它们能在所有情况下都帮到你吗？绝对不是。但它们有助于一点一点地攻克保留部分，同时也帮助学生理解。所以是的，仅仅使用检索练习就可以促进记忆和保留。话虽如此，它并不总是能促进最高水平的理解，因此学生需要做更多的事情，比如向自己解释内容。
So, for instance, how can I say apply a concept that is comprehended and use it if I don't remember it. So the idea here is the more we use these memorization strategies to learn difficult content that requires comprehension, the more will have that content available to us when we subsequently need to use it. So are any of these strategies that we describe, are they the panacea of all learning? So they're going to help you in all cases? Absolutely not. But they help chip away not only the retention component, but also helping students understand. So yes, just using retrieval practice can promote both memory and retention. That said, it won't always promote the highest levels of comprehension so students would need to do more, such as explain content
例如，去听讲座，这样他们就可以听到老师解释内容。他们可以尝试向自己解释事情或与老师交谈时辅以这些其他技术，以真正巩固他们的理解。因为我们不仅会忘记乘法表，我们还会忘记对微积分等内容的理解。这就是为什么我们必须回去重复，比如练习解决这些问题，从而带来对理解力和领悟力的长期保持。这就是我对它的看法。这些可以一直提供帮助，但学生需要多种策略来真正掌握任何特定的内容。金，也许我可以补充一个非常务实的例子。
to themselves. Say, for instance, go to a lecture so they can hear the instructor explain the content. And they can supplement this kind of instruction in trying to explain things to themselves or talk to their instructor with these other techniques to really solidify their understanding. Because not only can we, say, forget our multiplication tables, but we can also forget our understanding of, say, calculus. And that's why we have to go back and repeat, say, practicing our solving of those problems to lead to long-term retention of understanding and comprehension. So that's kind of my spin on it. these can help it always, but students are going to need multiple strategies to really master any particular content. And Kim, maybe I can add by, you know, a really pragmatic, you know, example.
以经典的抽认卡为例。许多学生，特别是在大型入门课程中，都在使用抽认卡。你知道，经典的方法当然是一面写术语，另一面写定义。当然，越来越多的学生在电子化地使用它，但这个想法是一样的。有一个术语，你点击一下，它就会闪现出定义。这听起来像是死记硬背，对吧？它确实是，对吧？但正如约翰所说，这也是非常重要的。但这就是我们讨论要更进一步的地方。所以一个非常好的方法，是在经典抽认卡之外增加两个简单的步骤。如果第一步是一面写术语，另一面写教科书定义，
And so take a classic example of flashcards. A lot of students, especially in large introductory classes, use flashcards. And, you know, the classic methodology, of course, is you have your term on one side and the definition on the other. Of course, more and more students are using it electronically, but the idea is the same. There's a term and you click something and it flashes to the definition. Now, that sounds like memorization, right? And it is, right? But it's also, as John said, really important. But here's where we talk about going further. So a really nice way to go, two simple steps beyond the classic flash card. So if step one is term on one
那么一个非常好的第二步是学生现在用自己的话写出定义。他们有了教科书的定义。现在他们正在用这些材料做一些事情，用他们自己的话写出来。还有第三步，它真正指向了学习。所以你有了教科书的定义。你有了自己话语的定义，现在想出一个例子。通过这种应用，对吧——这就是约翰谈到的进入更高学习水平的时候——通过拿起那个简单的基本抽认卡，把它变成你自己的话，然后想出一个应用，你更有保证能更好地记住那个概念。我说近乎保证是因为我有数据表明，这种方法——我们称之为“抽认卡加法”的方法——实际上比你只使用标准抽认卡方法在测验中带来更高的学习成果。
side textbook definition on the other, a really good second step is the student now writing the definition in their own words. So they've got the textbook definition. Now they're doing something with that material writing it in their own words. There's a third step that really goes towards learning. So you've got the textbook definition. You've got the definition in your own words now come up with an example. And by that application, right, and that's when John is talking about going to a higher level of learning, by taking that simple basic flashcard and going, putting it into your own words, and then coming up with an application, you are more guaranteed to remember that concept better. And I say near guaranteed because
向德鲁·阿普尔比（Drew Appleby）致敬，他首先向我介绍了这种想法。但我们已经测试过了，果不其然，它起作用了，超越了基础知识。这很重要。我认为很多时候，我希望约翰有机会谈谈我所说的经典的丹洛斯基2013年论文。但我这样称呼它的原因是约翰真的说过，看，这里有这些东西。
I've got data showing that this method, what we call the flashcard plus method, actually results in higher learning on quizzes than if you just use the standard flashcard method. a big shout out to Drew Appleby, who first introduced me to this kind of idea. But we've tested it, and sure enough, it's doing something, going beyond that basics. That's important. And I think far too often, I'm hoping John has a chance to talk a little bit about what I refer to as the classic Danloski-At-or 2013 paper. But the reason I refer to that way is John really said, look, here are these things. things that students often do, but here's how they vary in their utility. And I think, what I think
学生经常做的事情，但它们在效用上有所不同。我认为，我认为大多数人对我们需要做什么都有一个概念。其中许多事情不一定是最好的学习方法。我认为这就是为什么有研究表明“你知道，你可能认为荧光笔画重点很棒。是的，你向我展示了你的教科书，上面涂满了五颜六色的高亮。这可能不是——然后我们经常看到这一点——这不一定是最好的学习方法”是如此美好。你还谈到了做好笔记的重要性，我相信你发现手记笔记和在笔记本电脑上记笔记之间存在差异。
is what I think is most of us have an idea of what we need to do. Many of those things aren't necessarily the best way for learning. And I think that's why it's so nice to have research out there that says, you know what, you mean have thought highlighting is great. Yes, you've show me your textbook with all the five colors highlighting. That may not, and then that, you know, that we see that often. That's not necessarily the best way to learn. You've also talked about the importance of taking good notes, and I believe you have found that there's a difference between whether you take notes by hand or on your laptop.
如果其中一个比另一个更好，我们的大脑会发生什么？哪个更好？实际上，金，我最近对这一点做了相当多的研究。所以让我插话进来。底线是，作为一个整体，证据表明这两种记笔记的途径没有哪一个比另一个更好，无论是手写还是打字。我不会陷入所有这些细节的繁枝末节中，因为我想指出我认为比你使用的是手写还是电脑更重要的事情，好吧，我建议学生喜欢什么以及他们认为对特定课程最有效的方法就用什么。所有关于记笔记的研究中那个小小的秘密被称为对照组。这些实验中的对照组，他们坐着只是听讲座。他们不做任何笔记。
What's happening in our brains if one is better than the other, and which is better? Actually, I've done quite a bit of research on this recently, Kim. So let me kind of jump in here. And the bottom line is that the taken as a whole, the evidence indicates that neither pathway to taking notes is better than the other, whether you're longhand or typing. And I won't get into the nitty gritty of all of this because I want to point out something that I think is more important than whether you're using longhand or a computer, okay, which I'd recommend whatever students like the best and what they think is most effective for a particular class they go with. The little hidden secret of all the research on note taking is called the control group. And the control group in these experiments, they sit and they just listen to a lecture. They don't take any notes.
现在我要比较学生对那场讲座的知识，无论他们是没有做笔记（对照组），还是用手写或电脑做笔记。在许多许多情况下，这些小组在他们保留了多少内容方面没有任何区别。也就是说，只是坐在那里听讲座，你保留的内容和你记笔记保留的差不多。然而，没有哪个小组能保留那么多。没有哪个小组能保留那么多。所以这就是关键。不做笔记的小组，嗯，他们现在处于明显的劣势，因为他们没有任何东西可供学习来为考试做准备。
So now I'm going to compare students' knowledge about that lecture, whether they've taken no notes, the control group, or whether they've taken notes longhand or with a computer. and in many, many cases, none of those groups differ in how much they retain. That is just sitting listening to a lecture, you're going to retain about as much as you do by taking notes. However, none of the groups retain that much at all. None of the groups retain that much. So this is the key. The group who doesn't take notes, well, they're pretty much behind the eight ball now because they don't have anything to study to prepare themselves for the exam.
所以现在我将比较学生对那场讲座的知识掌握情况，不论他们是没有记笔记的对照组，还是手写记笔记，或者用电脑记笔记。在很多很多情况下，这些小组在保留知识的程度上没有任何区别。也就是说，仅仅坐在那里听讲座，你所记住的东西和记笔记差不多。然而，没有任何一个小组能记住多少内容。没有任何小组能记住那么多。所以这就是关键所在。不记笔记的那组人，现在他们可以说是处境艰难了，因为他们没有任何复习资料来为考试做准备。
So when we talk about the importance of notes, you don't necessarily get a lot out of taking them. But what you need to do is have good complete notes because the real learning is going to happen after the fact and how you interact and study those notes moving forward. So my recommendation, if you're in a class, say, where a teacher talks really, really fast, Well, you might be better off with a computer because if you can type fast, if you're in a class in mathematics where they're putting lots of equations on the board, probably a computer's not going to work well. You need to take longhand.
所以当我们谈论笔记的重要性时，记笔记本身其实并不能让你收获太多。但你需要做的是拥有完整且优秀的笔记，因为真正的学习会发生在事后，取决于你如何与这些笔记互动并在未来进行复习。所以我的建议是，如果你在一堂课上，比方说老师语速非常非常快，那么你用电脑可能会更好，因为如果你打字很快的话；但如果你在一门数学课上，黑板上有大量方程，电脑可能就不太适用了，你还是需要手写。
So really, I think the jury is out about which is better. I would say neither is better. But really, taking notes themselves, the magic happens after you get the good notes down, not while you're taking them. And, Kim, I think it's really important to remember when we're talking. about notes, that there are three actual purposes to notes. Yes, it's recording what happened, but it's an opportunity to review what's going on and then an opportunity to revise. And I think, you know, we would actually dedicate it an entire chapter to note-taking just because it's so
所以说实话，我认为究竟哪种更好还没有定论。我认为没有哪一种绝对更好。但实际上，记笔记这件事，神奇之处在于你记下好笔记之后，而不是在记的时候。而且，金，我觉得在谈论笔记时，有一点非常重要，那就是笔记其实有三个实际用途。是的，它是记录发生过的事情，但它也是一个回顾进展的机会，然后是一个修改的机会。而且我想，你知道的，我们实际上会用整整一章来讨论记笔记，仅仅因为它太
important and so underused. So one other thing to keep in mind when everybody thinks about laptop versus longhand, I think what many of those studies, Johns and others have found, is there is an important additional factor when we talk about a laptop versus no hands, is that any device that enables you to be distracted by something else can be problematic.
重要了，而且太少被充分利用了。所以，当大家考虑笔记本电脑与手写时，还有一点需要记住，我认为约翰等人以及其他许多研究发现，当我们在讨论笔记本电脑与手写时，有一个非常重要的附加因素，那就是任何能让你被其他事情分心的设备都可能是有问题的。
So you can be distracted if you are taking notes on a laptop and then you go to another tab and check your, you know, your messages, or you can be distracted if you're writing notes longhand and your phone modifies you and you decided to divide your attention and look at it. That's really what's seeming to be that there's that collateral damage there of laptops make it more likely to switch tabs and be distracted, which I think contributes in a long, long way to them being problematic with note taking. So, you know, focus, kept on those distractions. You see, that's a theme we keep coming back to. But boy, no matter what you're trying to learn, cutting down on these distractions is better.
因此，如果你用笔记本电脑记笔记，然后切换到另一个标签页去查看你的信息，你就会分心；或者如果你用手写记笔记，而你的手机提醒了你，你决定分散注意力去看它，你也会分心。这才是真正让人觉得笔记本电脑会带来这种伴随损害的地方——笔记本电脑更容易让人切换标签页并分心，我认为这在很大程度上导致了它们在记笔记方面存在问题。所以，你知道的，保持专注，远离这些 distractions（分心事物）。你看，这是我们不断重申的一个主题。但说实话，不管你想学什么，减少这些分心都是有益的。
What about cramming? I mean, every college student does it. You've got to test tomorrow. Oh, my God, you're panicking. You're going to stay up all night and you're really just going to slam it. Does it work? Does it get you maybe an A on the test? But then what happens long term?
那死记硬背（临时抱佛脚）呢？我的意思是，每个大学生都这么干过。明天就要考试了。天哪，你开始恐慌了。你打算熬夜一整夜，然后狠狠地突击一下。这管用吗？它能帮你考试拿A吗？但长远来看会发生什么呢？
I'm going to touch on just the knowledge component. I'll let Regan talk about how it disrupts sleep and performance and all that kind of thing. Certainly, depending on how difficult the test is, you can cram and get an A in your class. And I want all students out there to know that often that's fine. You don't have to remember everything that you do in college. That's okay. But if you really want to know something well, really want to retain it, say it's part of a major, or you're going to need this content, say, for a subsequent advanced course,
我只想谈谈知识成分。至于它如何打乱睡眠和表现之类的事情，我留给雷根来讲。当然，根据考试的难度，你可以通过临时抱佛脚在课上拿个A。我想让所有的学生都知道，通常这没问题。你不需要记住在大学里学的所有东西。这没关系。但如果你真的想把某个东西学好，真正想记住它，比方说它是专业课的一部分，或者你以后还会用到这些内容，比如后续的高级课程，
cramming likely will fail you because what happens is you'll learn it kind of just well enough to recognize and perform, like pass that performance threshold for that exam, but then you'll quickly forget that knowledge that you learn. So it won't be readily available when you take that advanced class. It'll be more difficult to relearn and so forth. So that's why using these other strategies like space practice can benefit you in the long term because you'll retain that knowledge longer. I still encourage my students because I know it makes them comfortable to study the night before, but if they've used these other techniques, spacing, retrieval practice, and so forth, getting ready, then that study session the night before will be an anxiety reducer because they'll
临时抱佛脚很可能会让你失败。因为会发生的情况是，你学的程度刚刚好到能够识别并通过那场考试的及格门槛，但之后你很快就会忘记学到的知识。所以当你上那门高级课程时，这些知识将不再随手可用。重新学习会变得更加困难，诸如此类。这就是为什么使用像间隔练习这样的其他策略能让你长期受益，因为你会更持久地记住这些知识。我仍然鼓励我的学生——因为我知道这能让他们感到安心——在前一天晚上复习，但如果他们使用了这些其他技巧，比如间隔、检索练习等等，做好了准备，那么前一天晚上的复习就会成为一种焦虑缓解剂，因为他们会
realize they know the content well and that they're ready to go, right? But cramming the whole, pulling an all-nighter, I think that's a horrible idea. I don't know. Regan probably always did it when he was in college, but I certainly never did. I don't know. What do you think, Regan? Yeah, you know, I like to do that you tied in sleep in there because I think sleep is a pretty big deal. And that's, I think there are a lot of techniques that are not so much techniques, but life habits. And, you know, we spend the entire last chapter actually talking about eating and physical activity and sleep. But particularly in the context of cramming, I think the big part here to keep in mind is if you, if, if, if, if that night before is your first real dedicated attention to the material,
意识到自己对内容很熟悉，已经准备好应付考试了，对吧？但是临时抱佛脚，通宵达旦，我认为这是个糟糕的主意。我不知道。雷根上大学时可能总是这么干，但我绝对没这么干过。我不知道。你怎么看，雷根？是的，你知道的，我很高兴你把睡眠联系进去了，因为我认为睡眠是一件相当重要的事情。而且，我认为有很多技巧与其说是技巧，不如说是生活习惯。你知道的，我们在最后一章花了一整章来讨论饮食、体育活动和睡眠。但特别是在临时抱佛脚的背景下，我认为这里需要记住的重点是，如果，如果，如果，如果前一天晚上是你第一次真正投入精力去学习这些材料，
yeah, you need to find the next day, but that is going to erode and fade very, very quickly. And as long as you have the spacing in there, absolutely you're going to feel better, you know, studying a little bit, some the night before. But I think, you know, it's how much sleep you get also makes a difference. one of the big reasons that there are many, many reasons to sleep a lot. I mean, there are a lot of functions of sleep that are important. But one of the ones most pertinent to, I think, this conversation is sleep is a time when memory consolidation takes place. You know, there's actual and not just memory consolidation, but even studies show that even problem solving is enhanced by sleep.
是的，你第二天可能会勉强应付过去，但那些知识会非常非常快地流失和消退。只要你中间有了间隔，毫无疑问你会感觉更好，你知道的，在前一天晚上稍微学习一下。但我认为，你知道的，你获得多少睡眠也很重要。有很多很多原因需要充足的睡眠。我的意思是，睡眠有许多重要的功能。但其中与我认为这次对话最相关的之一是，睡眠是记忆巩固发生的时间。你知道的，确实存在，不仅是记忆巩固，甚至研究表明连解决问题能力也会因为睡眠而增强。
if you actually benefit by struggling on a problem, stopping and going to bed, then staying up until you've solved it. And what I mean actually benefit, there are some great experiments that literally have people work on a pezzar, then go to bed, and lo and behold, those on waking up, they actually come up with a solution that they didn't have when they went to bed. So I think sleep before an exam is really important. I also want to say it's not just before an exam, more recent work on sleep shows that it's not just a day before an event that's important, but the accumulated sleep that you get up to a week before an important exam or an important performance thing. And this is stuff that just came out earlier this year.
如果你实际上能从在一个问题上苦思冥想、然后停下来去睡觉中受益，而不是熬夜直到把它解出来。我所说的真正受益是指，有一些极好的实验，字面意思上让人处理一个谜题，然后去睡觉，结果惊奇地发现，他们在醒来时，竟然想出了睡觉前没有想出来的解决方案。所以我觉得考试前的睡眠非常重要。我还想说，不仅仅是考试前，最近关于睡眠的研究表明，重要的不仅是事件发生前的一天，还有你在重要考试或重要表现前一周所积累的睡眠。这是今年早些时候刚出来的新研究。
It's that accumulated sleep because I've heard students say, oh, no, don't worry about to go wrong. I'll make sure I get enough sleep, the night before. And I say it's not just the night before. It's, you know, a few days coming up. But, yeah, you know, that's the thing is the bad news is students scram and they go, oh, I did well the next day.
这就是积累的睡眠，因为我曾听学生说：“哦，不，别担心会出错。我一定会在前一天晚上保证充足的睡眠。”我说，不仅仅是前一天晚上。你知道的，是前面好几天。但是，是的，你知道，问题在于坏消息是学生们临时抱佛脚，然后他们说：“哦，我第二天考得不错。”
And if that particular class doesn't have a cumulative final or a cumulative kind of test, they're not likely to realize that that cramming didn't serve them well. But particularly for those of our listeners who are no longer taking classes, this is even more important, right? Because you want to spread it out, you want to space it, you want to practice retrieval, because we want to remember this for the rest of our lives, or at least for a long time, and cramming will definitely not get you that. So I want to ask where the teaching of critical thinking figures into your work,
如果那门课没有期末综合考试或综合测试，他们就不太可能意识到这种临时抱佛脚并没有真正帮到他们。但特别是对于我们那些不再上课的听众来说，这一点甚至更加重要，对吧？因为你想把时间分散开，你想进行间隔，你想练习检索，因为我们希望在余生中，或者至少在很长一段时间内记住这些，而临时抱佛脚绝对做不到这一点。所以我想问，批判性思维的教学在你们的工作中占有什么位置？
are there methods that can help people do better at this? I'm asking that question in light of all the mis and disinformation, that we're being bombarded with right now, are some of the techniques that you talk about helpful in teaching students how to discern between things that are real and things that are fake? Yeah, I think the place that it comes in when I, A, think about the book
有没有什么方法可以帮助人们在这方面做得更好？鉴于我们目前正受到各种错误信息和虚假信息的狂轰滥炸，我提出这个问题是因为你们讨论的一些技术是否有助于教导学生如何辨别真假？是的，我认为当A、我想到这本书时
and B, think about studying and study techniques in general, is when we talk about deep processing, I mean, you know, when we set the stage in the first chapter, we talk about the importance of deeper processing, And very often, even when it comes to memory, questioning material leads to deeper processing. So, for example, in cognitive science, we often talk about shallow processing versus deep processing. The example here is if I ask you to memorize a list of words and you just think about, does it have the letter E in it or the letter S in it, Well, that's a very quick decision later on when I ask you to remember the words, you're not really going to remember them.
以及B、我想到学习和总体学习技巧时，批判性思维发挥作用的地方在于我们谈论深度加工的时候。我的意思是，你知道的，当我们在第一章奠定基础时，我们讨论了深度加工的重要性。通常情况下，即使在记忆方面，对材料进行质疑也会带来更深层的加工。例如，在认知科学中，我们经常讨论浅层加工与深层加工。这里的例子是，如果我让你背诵一词表，而你只是去想它里面有没有字母E或字母S，那是个非常快速的决定，稍后当我让你回忆这些词时，你其实并记不住它们。
On the other hand, if I ask you, when I read you a list of words, if I ask you, is this word a good word or a bad word? Automatically, you're doing more work with it, and lo and behold, you tend to remember more of the words that you've examined more deeply. Along those lines, when we actually critically think about words or information, that extra work that we do ongoing with does this map onto my previous knowledge. And previous knowledge is very important with learning. I mean, as an instructor, as a teacher, us knowing what that student already knows. As an adult learner, being aware of our experiences in our history becomes really important. in how we face new information. And I think it's in those contexts more indirectly that we talk about critical thinking.
另一方面，如果我问你，当我向你读出一张词表时，我问你，这个词是个好词还是个坏词？你自动地就会对它进行更多的处理，结果你会发现，你往往能记住更多那些你经过更深层检查的词。沿着这个思路，当我们真正对文字或信息进行批判性思考时，我们在不断进行的额外工作就是：这是否与我先前的知识相符？先前的知识对于学习非常重要。我的意思是，作为一名指导者、一名教师，我们需要了解学生已经知道什么。作为成年学习者，意识到我们的经验和历史在我们面对新信息时变得非常重要。我认为正是在这些更间接的语境中，我们才谈论批判性思维。
Let me close by asking you this question. Where do you think there are still knowledge gaps in understanding the best ways to teach? What are you looking at going forward for the second edition of your book? We have a lot of knowledge about what works best, right? From personal hygiene like brushing your teeth is a good idea, flossing is a great idea, using retrieval practice and success of re-learning great idea. However, say most of us know that flossing is wonderful and even understand the mechanisms. How many of us really regularly floss?
最后我想问你们这个问题。你们认为在理解最佳教学方法方面，知识还存在哪些空白？为了你们书的第二版，你们接下来在关注什么？我们对什么最有效有很多了解，对吧？从个人卫生习惯来看，比如刷牙是个好主意，用牙线剔牙是个极好的主意，使用检索练习和成功的回顾性再学习也是个极好的主意。然而，比方说我们大多数人都知道用牙线剔牙棒极了，甚至理解其中的原理。我们当中有多少人真的经常用牙线剔牙呢？
And the question is, now that we have all this wonderful knowledge about how to live healthier lives, how to become a better student, how do we motivate students, how do we motivate ourselves to use these best practices? So as much as I believe myself that goal setting, planning, and time management are tools for motivation, wow, I wish we had a chapter in there that described, look, these are tried and true techniques to help you motivate yourself to do the best things in the long run. And I know there's some techniques students can use, but I know we need a lot moving in that direction to really develop really foolproof ways for motivation.
问题是，既然我们拥有了所有这些关于如何过上更健康的生活、如何成为更好的学生的精彩知识，我们该如何激励学生、如何激励我们自己去使用这些最佳实践呢？因此，尽管我自己相信设定目标、规划和时间管理是激发动机的工具，但天哪，我真希望书中能有一章来描述，看，这些是经过考验的真实技巧，可以帮助你激励自己在长期内做最好的事。我知道有一些学生可以使用的技巧，但我知道我们需要朝着这个方向做很多努力，才能真正开发出万无一失的激励方法。
So that would be my addition to the book. Dr. Gurung, what about you? Yeah, I actually think about, you know, and motivation is great. I mean, we touch on motivation, we touch on, you know, getting social support and help when you need it because that's really important. That's definitely something that can be expanded on. But when I think about what's really needed here, I'm reminded of all the instructors, all the thousands and thousands of instructors working so hard who don't know. know or were never trained in cognitive science or teaching for that matter. And here I'm talking about higher education.
所以这就是我对这本书的补充。古隆博士，你呢？是的，我其实在想，你知道的，动机固然很好。我的意思是，我们触及了动机，我们触及了，你知道的，在你需要时获得社会支持和帮助，因为这真的很重要。这绝对是可以扩展的内容。但当我思考这里真正需要的是什么时，我想起了所有那些辛勤工作、却并不了解认知科学或根本没有接受过教学培训的数以千计的教师们。这里我指的是高等教育。
You know, most of us in higher education with PhDs didn't necessarily go have a teaching program. I mean, there were some great grad programs that did, but many teaching programs didn't. That's why, you know, APO's division on the Society for the Teaching of Psychology is such a great resource. but when I think about next edition of the book, I actually think of a compliment to the book. And John, I think here you go. First time you heard of this. But, you know, next to study like a champion,
你知道的，我们在高等教育中拥有博士学位的大多数人，不一定都去读过教学项目。我的意思是，有一些很棒的研究生项目确实有，但许多教学项目并没有。这就是为什么，你知道的，美国心理学协会（APA）的心理学教学分会是一个如此极好的资源。但当我想到书的下一版时，我其实想到的是这本书的一个姊妹篇。约翰，我想这里就要提到你了。你这是第一次听到这个想法。
I think we need teach like a champion. And, you know, where we really address this book to students. So it's like, you know, we've taken out as much of the jargon as possible. We've put it in really pragmatic tips, but it's aimed at the student. And, oh boy, yeah, I hope some. I hope many faculty sneak a copy in and, you know, get their training done pretty quickly. But I really see writing one completely directed at faculty where we can help them anticipate the problems that students have and help them solve it. Well, this has been really interesting.
但我认为，除了《像冠军一样学习》（Study Like a Champion）之外，我们需要《像冠军一样教学》（Teach Like a Champion）。而且，你知道的，我们要把这本书真正面向学生。所以就像是，你知道的，我们去掉了尽可能多的行话。我们把它变成了非常务实的建议，但它是针对学生的。天哪，是的，我希望有些。我希望很多教职员工能偷偷买一本，然后，你知道的，很快就能完成培训。但我真正看到的是写一本完全直接针对教职员工的书，我们可以帮助他们预测学生遇到的问题并帮助他们解决。好吧，这真的很趣。
I very much appreciate you're both joining me today. Thank you so much. Thanks for having us. Yeah, thanks so much, Kim. For those of you who are interested in getting a copy of a study like a champ, the psychology-based guide. to grade A study habits, you can order it on APA's website. Go to www.8.org and click on publications and databases to get to our book section. Or look for directions in our podcast notes.
非常感谢你们俩今天加入我。非常感谢。谢谢邀请我们。是的，非常感谢，金。对于那些有兴趣购买一本《像冠军一样学习：基于心理学的A级学习习惯指南》的人，你可以在APA的网站上订购。访问 www.apa.org 并点击“出版物与数据库”进入我们的图书板块。或者在我们的播客笔记中寻找指引。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condiyan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association,
你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在苹果、Spotify 或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学纵横》（Speaking of Psychology）以前的节目。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发邮件至 Speaking of Psychology at apa.org。本节目由李·温纳曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。我们的音频编辑是克里斯·康迪安（Chris Condiyan）。谢谢收听。美国心理学协会出品，
I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是金·米尔斯。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。